tu connais les ados moi j'en ai une bon
on vient de se séparer parce qu'elle me
trouve un peu immature
[Musique]
non j'accueille Gaspard Proust pour elle
est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
je l'aime un peu
beaucoup passionnément
à la folie il est où l'avion je l'aime
un peu beaucoup
mais François qu'est-ce qui te prend on
est en hiver la nature d'or et toi tu
roucoule comme une palombe sous ecstasie
enfin
François toi président moi désolé
moi je commence à mieux comprendre
pourquoi tu étais tellement inquiet pour
ta prostate parce que
tu en as besoin en ce moment
[Applaudissements]
c'est non mais je sais mais c'est quand
même passionnant ce qui se passe je veux
dire mais on est vernis la chance
d'avoir dans la tête depuis une semaine
cette image de Hollande en train de
culbuter une meuf c'est
moi non mais c'est simple moi depuis les
vidéos porno sur le thème nain et femme
enceinte j'ai jamais été autant excité
parce qu'il faut pas se mentir on a tous
envie d'imaginer Hollande en levrette
c'est ben oui mais bien sûr mais s'il
vous plaît soyez sérieux quoi comment il
s'y prend comment il bouge tu te
racontes les scénario tu l'imagines
arriver tout fringant tu vois sur le
scooter personne à gauche je pense à
droite bam la Pompadour tu vois le truc
alors on dit que c'est une affaire
privée c'est pas vrai pendant que
Hollande cavale comme un ado qui fait
l'amour à la France
mais
maintenant tout s'explique c'est son
envie du mariage pour tous c'est normal
moi il y a de concurrence plus il y a de
choix
non mais le mec qui gère sa double vie
comme un héros du mail et les abeilles
je veux dire quand tu penses que
Mitterrand a réussi à cacher sa fille
pendant 20 ans
non parce que lui en terme de camouflage
il est pas prêt pour rejoindre la Légion
étrangère
[Applaudissements]
il arrive à se faire gauler dans le
quartier le plus surveillé de Paris par
un paparazzi de Closer non mais sa
maîtresse elle habite à 150 mètres de
l'Élysée sur ses 150 mètres tu passes
devant le ministère de l'Intérieur les
RG l'ambassade américaine l'ambassade
israélienne et lui il se fait gauler
comme un lapin dans les salles en fait
je veux dire ça
[Applaudissements]
alors
évidemment comme d'habitude la droite a
réagi avec l'intelligence qu'il a
caractérise donc par la voix de
Christian Jacob
non mais Jacob j'ai rien contre lui dire
si tu le mets dans l'amour et dans le
pré tu tiens l'Albert jacquard de la
saison c'est pas
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est plus tendu
c'est plus
pas toute cette affaire il dit toute
cette affaire ça montre qu'il y a une
faille dans la sécurité du président
au lieu d'en profiter
au début c'est perturbant mais il arrive
à le cacher comme il peut alors certains
tombent dans le panneau tout le monde
est tombé dans le panneau ici oui mais à
la conférence de presse il impressionné
il a dit oui je suis social-démocrate
mais non il est pas social-démocrate il
est amoureux
parce qu'en ce moment c'est un ado il
raconte n'importe quoi je veux dire
enfin tu connais les ados moi j'en ai
une bon on vient de se séparer parce
qu'on trouve un peu immature
[Musique]
une ado c'est quoi tu vois cette semaine
il est social-démocrate la semaine
prochaine il est gothique puis dans un
mois il va porter un t-shirt les jeunes
avec Giscard c'est
[Applaudissements]
la Cricri d'amour il faut laisser
galoper au lieu de le contredire faut
laisser couler ouais tu donnes de
l'argent de poche pour son flipper et
puis achètes une boîte de capote un déo
une bouteille d'eau précieuse vas-y tu
vois
alors forcément à un moment il devait
quand même parler de son histoire de
fesses moi je m'attendais un truc
pittoresque un truc comme ça tu vois
avec Carla c'est du sérieux lui je le
voyais dire avec Valérie c'est du sursis
alors on lui demande mais comment va la
Première Dame du cœur Bon elle se repose
c'est à l'impression qu'il porte sa
grand-mère oublier dans un hospice sur
la Côte d'Azur
quand il a dit ça j'imagine déjà valoche
en train de nourrir des signes en blouse
blanche mais ouais j'ai même tu vois
il paraît qu'elle récupère surtout sur
le a rapporté le l de cette semaine elle
doit être
laissez-le tranquille que volant de
laisser le enfin il faut qu'il s'éclate
de simplification alors pour se
renseigner moi j'ai suivi les statuts
facebook des intéressés trier en couple
mais c'est compliqué
Gayet célibataire mais ça se précise et
lui il a marqué c'est compliqué mais
j'ai prévu de créer un observatoire du
sentiment amoureux qui prendra la
décision
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr
bien sûr il est pas seul dans cette
histoire en face il y a une autre dame
qui Piaf et pourquoi elle pourquoi Julie
Gayet alors faut être honnête enfin il
s'est pas mis avec elle pour sa
filmographie
non c'est pas être méchant que de dire
ça je veux dire la meuf révélée en 96
par Delphine 1 il vend 0 tu sais le seul
film français que la lucidité d'annoncer
le nombre d'entrée dans son titre
[Applaudissements]
à Kennedy avait Marilyn tu les chantais
pompon Pidou au Congrès là là on va on
va vers quoi la Bellevilloise une meuf
qui va chanter le temps des cerises pour
une galette au quinoa enfin je veux dire
passons à des sujets plus sérieux santé
Bouteflika hospitalisé au Val de Grâce
qu'est-ce qu'il est arrivé il a fait une
chute de ski à Méribel il a fait
bon qu'il soit venu se soigner en France
c'est quand même l'aveu qu'on a eu la
colonisation un peu mesquine
non mais c'est pas que notre faute s'ils
avaient été un peu moins obnubilé par
leur désirs d'indépendance en plus des
routes et des égouts on aurait pu
laisser un système de santé qui marche
[Applaudissements]
c'est une idée bon bonne nouvelle de la
semaine il y en a-t-il une oui le Ballon
d'Or a été remis à Cristiano Ronaldo
certains disent que Ribéry le méritait
oui mais qui aurait traduit son discours
alors
pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu